I'm pulling together this teaching team
I kind of felt like Nick Fury from the
Avengers tapping into you know all these
people that I came across I there as a
student or working with who you know
video production the that was something
that we covered in the class like it's
not a solo effort and I think teaching
that your production very much is not a
solo effort so Chris and I had been
talking about this for several years I
feel like just going through your class
and then talking about the program and
the videos that we make we've just been
tossing around ideas and George and I
have worked together extensively she
said with a heavy side on science out
loud and Josh and I met at a conference
um purely by accident yeah um and I knew
you guys were doing awesome animation
work and that was something that I
didn't really feel like much expertise
on just like storyboarding in general
which which is really important for
students and for everyone really and
then we had a couple other just because
you're in there so it was really um so
teaching teaching something that doesn't
have an objective answer like you know
in physics there's a right answer to a
problem set for instance in meteor
production or creative writing or or
anything like this that you can't just
be like well this is what makes a good
answer necessarily i feel like something
that helps solidify our helps you come
to a good feedback mechanism for
students is to have people who are good
practitioners of of whatever media
you're making so you know if you're
teaching creative writing hopefully
you'd be a pretty good creative writer
if you're teaching media production or
storyboarding hopefully you're a good
animator story border hopefully you're a
decent host not all right tolerable
haha so that was why I from the
beginning I felt like it had to be a
team team effort to teach this class I
really like you had a skeleton outline
for the course and then you filled in
the parts that you were going to the
learning objectives for the parts that
you were going to do and then each of us
filled in our parts and then we all
commented on the other people's parts
which was a good way to do it it's
tricky because it's not like a linear
sort of knowledge comprehension format
where like first you learn scripting and
then you can learn storyboarding and
then you can learn hosting that's
actually how we first approached it and
it got really hairy because there was so
much overlap why did we approach it that
way we wanted to get hairy and well
because I think Chris initially you want
to yeah what did you what did you do
yeah there was a lot of coordination
that we and Josh tonight especially I
think we felt the need to coordinate
because there are things that are
similar when you're thinking about kind
of telling a story in animation and in
live action but there are also things
that that are different and we wanted to
make sure that we weren't overlapping
each other that we were kind of
complementary and not and not repetitive
or contradictory so I think we ended up
kind of restructuring a little bit the
first few courses sessions of the course
I remember but it was interesting
because in terms of like the big picture
learning objectives I worked with Jamie
a lot the other course instructor and
she has never done video production I
she wasn't familiar with the content but
she's more familiar with just
instructional design in general so she
would ask me all these questions that I
wouldn't necessarily think to to ask or
answer like at the end of the day what
are the skills that you want people to
have and then what are the sort of
learning objectives that you want them
to aspire to and those are two very
different things right is like I don't
really care if they were you know
masters at final cut by the
because that it doesn't really matter
the objective is can you articulate a
clear story but she and i would meet to
sort of figure out what is the big
picture learning objectives that we want
and then it was a matter of how can we
take all these details and all these
very important plastic elements and pick
out the most relevant ones to match to
the objectives